cuál recta numérica representa 47 más 22
a ver veamos qué pasa en esta primera
recta numérica
empezamos en 47 y luego sumamos 20 y
entonces llegamos al 67 y después
sumamos otros 2 y llegamos a 69 y bueno
si primero sumamos 20 y después sumamos
2 estamos sumando 22 en total así es que
esta es una respuesta correcta pero que
hay porque empezamos en 47 y sumamos 22
en total pero ahora veamos qué pasa con
estas otras dos rectas numéricas para
ver en esta empezamos en 47 sumamos 2 y
llegamos a 49 y volvemos a sumar 2 y
llegamos a 51 pero pues esto no es sumar
22 ok porque si primero sumamos 2 y
luego 2 en realidad estamos sumando 2
más 2 o sea 4 en total para sumar 22
necesitan
y mucho más porque necesitamos algo así
como primero sumar 20 y después sumar 2
y en esta otra recta numérica si estamos
sumando primero 20 y después 2 o sea que
si estamos sumando 22 en total pero no
estamos empezando en 47 estamos
empezando en 74 entonces se está
representando 74 más 22 no 47 más 22 así
es que esta opción tampoco es una buena
opción por lo que me siento más segura
de que esta es la respuesta correcta
pero bueno vamos con el siguiente
ejercicio
cuál recta numérica representa 93 menos
76 a ver veamos en estas tres rectas
numéricas en todas estas empezamos en 93
en esta primera recta numérica
empezamos restando 7 y luego 6 pero para
restar 76 primero tenemos que restar 70
y después 6 no podemos simplemente
restar 7 así es que esta opción queda
descartada por aquí empezamos restando
60 y después 7 pero pues eso es restar
67 176 tenemos que restar primero 7
decenas
y después 6 unidades ok y bueno por acá
estamos restando 7 decenas o 70 y luego
6 unidades
así es que aquí sí estamos restando 76
por lo que esta es la respuesta correcta
bueno vamos con el siguiente ejercicio
cuál es la recta numérica que representa
12 87 y observamos estás rectas
numéricas todas empiezan en 12 entonces
vamos bien pero ahora queremos primero
sumar 80 y después 7 que queremos sumar
8 decenas y 7 unidades y a ver veamos a
ver aquí está primero suma 80 y después
suma 7 entonces esta es la respuesta
correcta y ya terminamos